- don't tell me that no I just forgot to
tell you that
what happens when two black holes
collide you get a bigger black hole you
get a big black hole is one possibility
which I think the mass depending it
depends on what the black holes are
doing I think I believe it's never been
observed it's it's thought to happen so
since every galaxy has a black hole in
the middle of it and we know that one of
the ways you get bigger galaxies is by
merging galaxies together then
presumably the galaxies merge together
their black holes then spiral into the
center and they end up merging to form a
bigger black hole
so probably whenever two galaxies merge
you end up ultimately merging two black
holes together if they come together
relatively slowly then they can sort of
merge together and you'll create a big
black hole that's got a mass which is
actually less than the sum of the two
masses because it releases energy we've
never seen it directly there are
actually experiments underway now to try
and detect it because one of the things
that happens is when two black holes are
in that kind of final phase of spiraling
in together they actually end up giving
away a lot of their energy as things
called gravitational waves so if you
have a gravitational wave detector one
of the strong signals that those
gravitational wave detectors are likely
to detect is the in spiraling of black
holes just as they merge together to
form a bigger black hole so within the
next twenty or thirty years hopefully
this is something that we will witness
directly but many black holes are
spinning and some of them the
supermassive black holes in that in the
Centers of galaxies are spinning really
really quickly so and I've heard of some
simulations which you know modeling
galaxies colliding and then of course
they've got these super massive black
holes millions of times the mass of the
Sun there's hundreds of millions of
times with some of them spinning really
rapidly and the simulation suggests that
actually what can happen is that there's
their birth spinning and it's like
spinning tops coming and they can
actually bang together and one can be
bounced out just totally out of the
system altogether leaving you with this
big one so they're not it doesn't look
like they always merge and often they
can go out so I think it depends on
what's actually happening to the black
hole's themselves as to what the the
fate of it will be so one of the amazing
things about this is if one of these
pairs are massive
coal's merges together anywhere in the
in the universe pretty much then the
kind of detectors they're building now
will actually be able to detect it so
we'll be able to see this phenomenon
right across the universe so even if it
only happens very rarely if it happens
anywhere in the universe we will
actually see it happening are you
someone who can discuss and enjoy the
beauty of a sunset or use someone who
take all that time thinking about the
atmospheric effect on sun rays and
things like that I'm thinking about the
science behind it but that's making me
enjoy it even more the universe is a
pretty amazing place and it's even more
amazing when you understand what's going
on or a bit of what's going on behind it
oh you would course you would join but
you enjoy them oh I spent all my time to
give this elusive green flash eye every
time I see a sunset of the distant
horizon I always look and some people
who I respect tell me that it's there
it's some kind of visual optical optical
effect perhaps in our eyes rather or a
way our brain processes like but I've
always looked for this and I've never
found it but cause every call scientists
like real sunsets and sunsets in the
paintings of Claude Lorrain
tremendous yeah perhaps Claude Rains
sunsets are even better than natural
ones we just had just been on holiday to
south west of France and we were in a
really rural place with some friends who
came out and just said ask me to come
outside one evening with them and and
there was the Milky Way I mean the real
Milky Way right the one where you see
the band going straight across the sky
unfortunately even though we live in a
fairly rural place here there's still
obviously too much light to spot that
but this was just a band of light going
across and I didn't spend my time
thinking well how many can i see how
many stars are in there and how are
those stars forming I just thought wow
that's bloody amazing that I'm family
was really neat I don't think that
explaining the details of how it works
takes away from its beauty at all so
they're completely continuous now I will
look at the sunset and take photographs
or it and say how beautiful it is and my
wife will drag me to see in the
moonlight and everything like that and
you can enjoy it I guess
I would flatter myself to say that I can
do both at once that actually did you
know this because people kind of think
well you know when you understand the
science or something that takes somehow
the tracks from the beauty of it I don't
think it does I can you know both
appreciate the beauty of a rainbow say
and actually enjoy the fact that I
understand why is there and I don't
think there's really any any paradox any
contradiction between doing both at the
same time I think one of the things that
Fineman sets and which is I think so
true what one of them perhaps advantages
that people like myself will work in
this area have is that not only can I
love the beauty of it for it for its own
sake but then I can actually begin to
think about the beauty of the
mathematics that describes it and that
so there's an additional beauty if you
like which adds on to it it doesn't take
away from the from the beauty you know
again coming back to fine man you know
the fact that you look at that sunset
and you you you think about what I was a
light scattered and and and how the
physics of that doesn't diminish from
the beauty that sounds that in fact it
increases that the beauty of that sunset
is that what you say to your wife when
she says do you think I'm beautiful
perhaps or put it in those terms no but
that's another thing you know I I've you
know my wife my children I loved love
dearly love to you know to use that that
that I cliche with all my heart and soul
but the fact you know that you can also
consider love and emotions or think
about love and emotions philosophically
in terms of biochemical pathways or
whatever doesn't diminish that no so I
mean you might understand where the
moonlights coming from and where all the
different patterns in the sky coming
from and you get a certain joy from
understanding where a rainbow comes from
or any of these other things but the
aesthetic sense the sense that the world
is a beautiful place to live in the rest
of the universe is hostile but the earth
is wonderful and it ought to be
preserved and and you see nature and
dragonflies and all sorts of other
things in your garden II that's just
wonderful but that must be true of
everybody surely I see the same sunsets
and rainbows as everybody else
you